cute okay huh that part's over I've  reached the relative safety of the first  branch but I gotta go another 20 feet  the fruits are way up in the top of the  canopy up here one slip would mean  certain death but the reward is worth  the risk  Oh beautiful durian right here  one more little wife okay the most  dangerous part is getting down these are  prickly weighing up to seven pounds each  spiky fruit contains five bulbs and  there it is just like that yeah doesn't  smell very nice right durian gives off  an odor a bit like raw sewage and it's  so strong that it's actually banned from  some public areas in Southeast Asia  so this GUI looks like egg yolks yeah it  tastes like like onion ice cream with  natural gas  it may not be the tastiest food I've  ever had but each pound is packed full  of nutrients  [Music]  I'll eat as much of this as I can muster  I got a long journey ahead  [Music]